well the world is changing and I think
adapting is also good I Meredith Bragg
from recent TV we are at the next
pavilion the newest Pavilion at the
Cannes Film Festival it's a new area a
new space in can here in the village
intl pantyho which gathers all different
companies of new models of all
alternative models in film from
storytelling to distribution
crowdfunding video on demand marketing
cinema on the man so which it's a wide
range of companies that are here on the
next all under one roof so people can
come and meet with them and on the other
side we have as well a program of
conferences workshops and panels all
around these questions of the future of
film what was the impetus behind doing
this well it responds to a need of the
participants of the marché need of the
industry of film in general digital is
changing everything and we're starting
to have a more natural also behavior
with the with technology and this
influences a lot in the storytelling in
the production everything today you can
do everything through the digital
through a platform from writing your
film from getting financing from
distributing by yourself it's like
you're your own gatekeeper as a
filmmaker and that's only because of
technology is this the more optimistic
side of the film industry new models new
iterations crowdfunding I mean MC
multi-platform VOD like new
opportunities I think yes it's a bit of
the what we are not answering to
anything it's what I say we're just
exploring now we are trying to figure
out what's going to happen with the
with the world of cinema but I think in
a way that it's we are showing all
creative responses to a state of the art
of cinema which is changing and I think
yes a lot of new models are helping
especially independent films and
filmmakers and I think what the
optimistic part of the whole thing is
that we are now listening more to the
audiences and that's very important and
all these new models give the choice to
these audiences it's all about that
crowdfunding cinema on the man is like
the audience has the power somehow and
and I think that's a good thing we if we
can choose it it becomes more democratic